عليه و لتصحيح مسار الثوره تقرر الاتي
اعلان حاله الطوارئ في جميع انحاء البلاد
واعلن لكم
استقالتي من منصب رئيس الوزراء
[موسيقى]
ما حدث لا يمكن ان نطلق عليه انطلاق لانه
انقلاب نجوم على حكومه منتخبه دائره
بتفويض عسكري والعسكريين يكونوا موجودين
في السكنات او في في معسكرتهم
كل مواطن سوداني ان هذا انقلاب
[موسيقى]
25 اكتوبر هم الشهداء الراح وضحيه
الانقلاب الجنرالات القهوه
[موسيقى]
بصفه رئيسا لمجلس السياده وغائدا عاما
للقوات المسلحه
الاتي عدم مشاركه المؤسسه العسكريه في
المفاوضات الجاريه حاليا ويتحدث عن وحده
القوه المدنيه
لتشكيل حكومه السؤال الذي يطرح نفسه من
الذي يعتمد الحكومه
وعلى السلطه
المبادرات على مستوى الساحه السياسيه
السودانيه الى
مبادراتهم اصابع اليد ولكن ذلك لا يعني
بان
التوافق التامه لانه هناك تعاند من جهات
اخرى وخاصه من الحريه والتغيير المجلس
القصه بتاعه
المدنيين
حكومتها دي نوع من ذاته لانه هو نحن عرفنا
واحنا نتوافق نهائي
[موسيقى]
عايزين السكنات لكن قبل ما يمشي
بالتحديد يمكن العسكري يعني كامل الذكاء
لحد ما ترك الكره في ارض كل القوه
السياسيه
[موسيقى]
حول هذه الوثيقه
من مركزيه الحريه والتغيير
الان هنالك حديث عن ان هذه الوثيقه الان
لا زالت في طور التنجيح وفي طور التعديل
ومطروحه للقوه السياسيه لكي يبدو
ملاحظاتهم عليها
الشعب السوداني ان يعرف مخرجات الثورته
حوار مباشر مع قاده المكونه العسكري همم
بقدرنا
بالمشاركه في هذا الحوار همم اجنده الثوره